thierry claveau bonjour bonjour vous
êtes candidat pour l'élection municipale
au carbet alors pourquoi avoir choisi
d'être candidat
cette fois-là au carbet et non pas à
saint pierre comme par le passé
écoutez d'abord je suis candidat tête de
liste d'une liste est super candidat
seul et j'ai choisi le carb et parce que
je suis habitants du gard b1 depuis
quelques quelques mois à j'habite le
carbet et j'ai été pendant 13 ans à la
mairie du carbet où j'ai exercé
notamment les fonctions de directeur de
cabinet d'alexandre mauvaise qui a été
maire pendant sept ans au carbet voilà
un petit peu et je me sens interpellé
monsieur pour cette belle commune qui
qui a un potentiel extraordinaire tant
sur le site du point de vue de la mer
que la campagne puisque c'est un c'est
un village très beau la population du
caire b d'une population très
intéressante
moi je connais bien et qui me connaît
bien c'est vrai que je suis parti pour
des vents c'est normal pour des raisons
professionnelles je me suis un petit peu
loin du territoire mais ne montre
demeure pas moins que j'ai beaucoup d
attache au carbet que je me sens
interpellé par ces territoires danse est
une commune que vous connaissez bien
tout autant que celle de saint pierre
vous aviez était candidat à l'élection
municipale par le passé alors j'étais
candidat aux municipales sur une liste
n'était pas tête de liste au cas c'est
assez fier et effectivement parce que je
suis pire au t1 de naissance j'ai vécu
toute ma jeunesse
effectivement à saint pierre mais j'ai
eu beaucoup d'action au carbet j'ai eu
l'occasion et de parfums ne serait ce
que sur l'aspect professionnel j'ai eu à
servir la population de du carbet
pendant de nombreuses années et je pense
se n'avons pas démérité dans mes
fonctions
thierry claveau si vous êtes élue maire
du carbet donc en mars prochain
quel est le chantier numéro un pour vous
quel est le dossier sur lequel
vous penseriez tout de suite là alors
d'abord je pense que aujourd'hui les
communes d'une manière générale sans
vouloir viser une en particulier et
singulier mois peut-être le carb et
souffre d'un problème de méthode
parce qu'il ya un problème de méthode
c'est à dire que il faut réfléchir à
long terme il faut avoir une vision de
son territoire alors moi je pense que le
premier chantier que je vais faire c'est
douter cette commune de vrais centres
administratifs permettant d'accueillir
la population et particulièrement le
personnel dans des conditions de
sécurité 1 et pour permettre de leur
donner de bonnes conditions de travail
pour qu'ils puissent donner le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes ça c'est dans un premier
temps et dans un deuxième temps je
m'occuperai d'établir un schéma
directeur d'aménagement du territoire
qui permettra de savoir exactement
quelle vision devra voir maman ma
majorité municipale sur 10 ans du
territoire du carbet parce qu'il faut de
la cohésion dans tout ça il faut pas
partir à la petite semaine médecin un
aménagement par là une petite ou tu fais
parle un petit ou trois par là il faut
vraiment avoir une vision de son
territoire et sur du moyen terme et ça
permet aussi de contractualiser avec les
partenaires institutionnels
quand il s'agira de passer à la
réalisation
selon vous quel sera le l'enjeu
principal dans cinq mois en mars 2020
pour
le carbet et surtout l'écart bastian et
des quarts des siens pour donc les
habitants de cette ville en
contextualisant sachant que donc nous
sortons de deux mandats successifs du
maire sortant 1
voilà ce qu'est pour eux l'enjeu je
pense que dans un premier temps c'est de
faire un état des lieux de la situation
parce que je crois savoir parce que je
n'ai pas encore les éléments entre mes
mains mais je conçois que les finances
communales ne sont pas en profondeur que
c'est général d'une manière générale
mais si je crois que le chaos b pendant
douze années n'a pas mis en place une
politique qui lui permet justement de se
maintenir sur le plan financier alors
que je me souviens en 2008 avoir laissé
mon bureau de la mairie du quartier
puisque je dirais que le cabinet dont je
partais avec celui qui avait été battu
eh bien je me souviens que les finances
communales quand même se protège bien
mieux donc je pense que l'enjeu
principal c'est ça c'est de rétablir
l'équilibré
le vrai équilibre pas les climats par an
1 de la situation financière de cette
commune et puis voir dans quelle mesure
quelles sont nos marges de manoeuvre
pour pouvoir partir heureuse voilà merci
thierry claveau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions le rappelle vous êtes candidat
donc aux quarts b pour les élections
municipales de mars 2020 je vous
remercie